nasci na cidade de fortaleza tá e
concluiu que os cursos de terapia
ocupacional da universidade particular
na universidade de fortaleza e em 1996
psicologia também em fortaleza
mas quando vim pra belém suspende a
psicologia ea inicialmente em 1991
concluir o curso de psicologia
então pra mim assim a mudança
saí de uma cidade que era minha cidade
natal fortaleza com praia é que eu adoro
praia é pra vir pra cá a cidade de belém
foi uma mudança muito radical né e era
filhinha de mamãe é filha única até na
alerj meu filho nunca mais uma menininha
pequenininha mas haverá a a única é a
mais nova mais velha né econômico quando
eu sai de fortaleza meu pai disse nossa
ainda embora o sustentáculo da família
porque eu era que coordenava algumas
coisas na família e de repente vim pra
belém sem conhecer ninguém né e
desbravar realmente a cidade que e eu
assumi como minha cidade que belém
então hoje assim eu tenho 34 vou fazer
34 anos de belém 32 anos de belém e tem
toda a minha trajetória profissional
praticamente foi construída aqui nessa
cidade estão iniciando uma trajetória de
muito crescimento pessoal tinha na época
22 anos né com pelo barreiras e partindo
para novos desafios rumo ao desconhecido
vários sonhos construindo novos sonhos
reconstruir desconstruindo alguns
conceitos algumas crenças né e partiu
com reconstrução de identidade sozinha
na realidade sozinho assim com meu
parceiro que o meu marido
e aí em greve foi quando eu comecei
cheguei belém se hoje a terapia
ocupacional é conhecida imagina a 32
anos atrás né
ninguém conhecia o que era área e partir
para visitar instituições que poderiam
inserir esse profissional né no trabalho
né e aí assim me engajei já como membro
do conselho de de terapia ocupacional e
fisioterapia e as visitando instituições
apae hospitais psiquiátricos secretaria
de saúde né e aí com os e paralelamente
construindo o projeto do curso dentro da
universidade do estado do pará
eu fui uma das fundadoras do curso da
universidade do estado do pará é que eu
cheguei 1984 e já em 1985 curso abre em
abril de 1985 abriu a primeira turma e e
aí eu entrei na carreira docente e fui a
primeira a terapeuta ocupacional a ser
contratada pela secretaria de saúde no
momento fui discutir com o secretário de
saúde o que era profissão o que fazia o
terapeuta é a gente conseguiu se
encaixar dentro da secretaria de saúde
sem influência política nenhuma que não
conhecia ninguém né
com a cara ea coragem bate na porta do
secretário de saúde e fui me engajei da
secretaria de saúde atualmente só vou
tentar me aposentei em janeiro
são 32 anos com terapeuta ocupacional
inicialmente comecei dentro do hospital
psiquiátrico eu acho que a maioria das
pessoas aqui não sabem não conhece nunca
ouviu falar no hospital juliano moreira
é que era um grande hospital na cidade
de belém que na época já estava no
processo de desconstrução nem na china
antes nós tínhamos quando chegou ele
chegou a ter 800 pacientes psiquiátricos
nem quando eu entrei no hospital tinha
apenas 200 pacientes em mulheres sem
homens e passou por todo o processo de
desconstrução da saúde mental daqui a
crise em si nem ficou eu me engajei
também no grupo antes de entrar na área
da defesa
e se me engajei também no grupo de
discussão porque é que os dois da
sociedade ficavam internados e sendo
médico alisados né é realmente fora
totalmente fora da sociedade e em treino
no processo de discussão foi indicada
pela secretaria de saúde para ir a
brasília fazer uma discussão sobre a
desconstrução dos selos das unidades
psiquiátricas
a quebra é realmente aquela coisa dos
grilhões prender até porque na realidade
espaço em psiquiatria ficaram presos
dentro das instituições psiquiátricas ea
gente implantou na época fiz parte desse
grupo de trabalho de todo mês em
brasília é e há uma mudança desse
domingo o ministro da saúde por onde o
projeto que caiu por água abaixo até que
depois foi recursos rené reconquistado
ea gente conseguiu implantar o que a
gente hoje tem uma rede de atenção em
saúde mental que somos um centro de
atenção psicossocial são os capps que
atende o paciente fora dos hospitais
tentando que ainda precisa de muita
discussão não é mas tentando tirar
aquela questão da internação total para
que manter realmente esse paciente em
contato com a sociedade precisa
reformulações né
daí por isso eu saí da área da saúde
mental foi quando eu comecei há
realmente fazer uma crise de identidade
não conseguia ver muitos resultados
nessa área e comecei a mim seria um
pouco na questão da área infantil foi
quando eu fui chamada pra ir trabalhar
na associação de pais e amigos dos
excepcionais e trabalhei durante 10 8
anos na pai né e aí foi atendendo um
paciente com crianças e adolescentes com
desenvolvimento típico e o que já indica
a necessidade de investigação científica
nesta área
eu acho que kaká acho que a gente tem
então aí assim a partir de fui em busca
de engajamento de colocação profissional
quando cheguei né
e aí fiz especialização na área de
métodos de de tratamento com criança
deficiente com criança com problemas de
desenvolvimento
fui para são paulo não tinha em belém
foi a são paulo é e aí vem cheia de
sonhos o que a gente podia reformular
para que essas crianças tivessem melhor
qualidade de vida né então trabalhei na
apae foi 99 1993 fui para são paulo é eo
meu foco foi sempre atender crianças com
atraso de desenvolvimento né com défices
e psicomotores que não conseguiu
realmente ter um avanço na questão da no
desenvolvimento que a gente podia ver o
que a gente podia fazer melhor
nessa questão e foi meu foco de pesquisa
até hoje né ea em 1996 a 2010 foi
idealizadora e e sócia de um centro de
desenvolvimento infantil que logo depois
eu eu fui nós fundamos também é ele era
particular e paralelamente à china um
trabalho com crianças que não tinham
acesso econômico que é a associação de
assistência à criança com deficiência da
amazônia
e aí em 1997 dentro de uma das crianças
que a gente atendia
é teve uma criança que me chamou muita
atenção essa criança ela tinha paralisia
cerebral com bastante comprometimento
motor mas tentava se comunicar com a
gente e não conseguia
e essa criança eu fui a um aniversário
dela é todas as pessoas que foram a seu
gosto muito dessa história com os alunos
porque foi o que o na realidade mudou
sim é todas as pessoas que foram ao
aniversário dela deram um presentinho
tipo perfume pijaminha camiseta sandália
ninguém de um brinquedo ea criança tinha
na faixa etária de cinco anos né a
criança que não se movia é corretamente
não falava e aquilo me chamou bastante
atenção
pra mim essa sorte ela era neta era não
é neta de uma uma pessoa que morava nos
estados unidos
lavou paraense mas a avó americana e
comentou que foram umas férias no centro
em eu já sei eu não falo fluentemente
inglês - ainda é e quando a mãe chegou
relatando que ela viu lá eu tive muito
interesse de conhecer né
não existia a internet né então foram
foi por fax que eu passei uma carta
pedindo pra mim para que eu pudesse ir
até lá conhecer o trabalho em ijaci aí
foi quando eu fui né
o primeiro intercâmbio fora do país o
despertar de uma grande paixão para
aliar tecnologia com a qualidade de vida
das pessoas deficientes a tecnologia
assistiva vem muito mais frustrada
porque eu percebi que eu não sabia como
não sabia mexer com computador 1997 era
muito onde ainda não era o acesso que a
gente tem hoje
nós não tínhamos nada no brasil que
oferecesse aquela forma de comunicação e
aquela forma de acesso crianças que não
falam e não escrevem poder se comunicar
através de uns
sistema de digitalizado é se inscrever
com a mão mas escreveram através de um
sistema de escaneamento de varredura não
falar com a fifa com a voz mas tem um
sistema de tocar em algum botão e avós
ser digitalizada ou ser gravada e aquilo
me deu muito mais é um sentimento de
tentar romper e trazer essa tecnologia
para que incluísse essas crianças né na
sociedade então eu fui passei um mês lá
né
vendo o trabalho deles e voltei com
outra perspectiva e foi quando a gente
começou realmente a mexer um pouco
mexer com essa área
em 1997 foi quando ele também fundou a
associação porque a gente começou a
trabalhar também com crianças carentes
né o interesse em capacitar
profissionais e assim paralelo a isso eu
precisava também envolver alunos e
professores né da dae tava se discutir
no brasil
já a questão da integração da criança
com deficiência a integração dos
deficientes não modelo de inclusão mas o
modelo de integração e aí eu precisava
envolver profissionais que tiverem a
sensibilidade de pensar dessa forma e de
trabalhar porque não adianta você tem só
a tecnologia se você não tiver o
profissional que se envolva com essa
tecnologia e que seja sensível a essa
criança a esse usuário a essa pessoa com
deficiente de deficiência porque entra a
questão das barreiras não são barreiras
é de equipamentos barreiras
arquitetônicas mas as barreiras
atitudinais e aí eu tinha que começou a
trabalhar com cursos de especialização
né e com cursos de formação de
profissionais para atuarem com pessoas
com deficiência
elaborei vários projetos de com
especialização primeiro projeto de com
especialização no pará é em terapia
ocupacional foi o que elaborei né a
gente namorou conseguiu trazer os
professores todos de fora eo primeiro
curso de especialização em capacitação
de professores para trabalhar com a
educação inclusiva também foi na uepa
coordenado por
i am então aí fui atrás de me capacitar
para poder entrar nas linhas de fomento
dos órgãos de governo
eles exigiam que a pessoa tivesse
mestrado doutorado e eu não tinha então
assim o primeiro projeto que eu fiz que
foi o projeto da finep do da aprovação
do núcleo que atualmente coordena na
realidade o nome de um colega porque eu
não podia ser coordenadora porque eu não
tinha a titulação então eu fui atrás de
fazer mestrado e no mestrado a gente
desenvolveu o software desenvolve que é
um software desenvolvido com pessoal de
tiê né
a gente fez todo o design do software é
a principal ponte que eu queria que
movesse o que eu queria que falassem que
eu queria que fizesse ação né como é que
tinha que seu feedback e contratei uma
pessoa de uti para desenvolver e com
self desenvolve que tinha condições de
acessibilidade
a gente conseguiu é com cinco crianças
que essas cinco crianças conseguissem
passar pelo teste cognitivo porque eu
percebi que nós não tínhamos no brasil
quando eu vim estados unidos trouxe
algum software mas todos enfim inglês e
que não tínhamos no brasil
softwares que avaliasse o cognitivo
dessa criança que não falava que não
escrevia né como é que eu sabe como é
que a professora pode saber se aquela
criança sabe a cor vermelha e amarela e
azul né tv disse ela tudo pergunta que
com essa não sabe ela não consegue falar
né ou não consegue apontar dizer é isso
que escolha o amarelo ela não consegue
chegar até a mão apontar então eu
precisava criar um mecanismo para
perceber avaliar se essa criança estava
aprendendo o conteúdo que estava sendo
ministrado na sala e aí a gente criou o
software desenvolve e o software vem
como sistema de escaneamento ea criança
pode escrever sem usar a mão porque ele
vem buscando as letrinhas abcd
e aí na hora que passa na lei que vamos
ver vamos ver a palavra bola na hora que
passa a palavra a letra b ela aperta um
dispositivo ela só parou ela pisca o
olho ou ela bate com o pé
e esse dispositivo é conectado num
computador e ali ela vai escrever nem se
usa na mão e sem falar então eo shopping
ele desenvolve ganhou três prêmios né
nós ganhamos o prêmio finep em 2005
tecnologia social
ganhamos menção honrosa em 2007 também
na área de tecnologia social e ganhamos
o prêmio direitos humanos em 2007 né
pela presidência da república
aí resolvi fazer o segundo e intercâmbio
né
o segundo intercâmbio faço parte de um
comitê chamado comitê paranaense suri
que é ligada aos companheiros das
américas que eu fiz parte da família né
e fomos fiz um projeto para o rosto todo
financiado por huacho nosso projeto foi
aprovado e em 2004 fui eu novamente
estados unidos nem e aí nessa
experiência foi uma experiência já
totalmente direcionada para escolas
inclusivas né ea gente visitou o centro
de onde eu pude
ele visitou o centro de tecnologia
assistir as tic tecnologias da cidade
santilus nem aqui era coordenador
aqui é ser a coordenadora de de educação
inclusiva na cidade no distrito de são
luiz
eu não falo com fluentemente inglês
continuou falando e eles conseguiram que
a conseguiram pra mim esse rapazinho que
é filho de português e que falava
português e ele me acompanhar em toda a
minha trajetória porque eu coloquei como
condição quando falava inglês e o
projeto mesmo assim foi aprovada né
e foi assim muito interessante porque a
gente teve uma visão muito boa das
escolas inclusivas na cidade de santa
cruz
aqui são crianças que não falam que não
que não utilizo as mãos mas que na
escola estão com sistemas de comunicação
alternativa e consegue fazer com a
operações matemáticas escrever frases né
você vê que ele está com os vários
dispositivos uma lanterninha para
apontar aqui com a mãozinha da forma
como ele consegue né e aqui um
vocalizador para ele falar o que ele
queria alguns pontos eu quero quer que
que traga isso eu quero banheiro algumas
coisas base e aqui nós e assim essas
fotos foram tiradas meio na
clandestinidade que eu não pude tirar
porque ela não podia parecer a o rosto
das crianças não estão meio quando dava
para tirar de longe né
e assim servir a tecnologia dentro da
sala de aula que são escolas regulares
com 800 crianças dos quais 10 você das
crianças tinham deficiência e sim
tivesse uma criança na sala já
justificavam a ter um professor de apoio
né
uma diferença sim em 2004 a diferença
tremenda o brasil hoje já vê alguma é
alguma similaridade
mas há uma diferença muito grande e aí
assim siga eles tinham em alguns
momentos o aek chamado brasil aí
é que o apoio educacional especializado
mas isso é de uma escola imensa 800
crianças
ai tá aqui também aqui era uma sala de
autistas e foi a primeira vez que eu
tive a sala dentro de uma escola
inclusiva é mais uma sala de atendimento
de terapia ocupacional e fonoaudiologia
com o cachorro estimulando essas
crianças as crianças tinham algumas
autistas algumas com dislexia e
começamos a nossa experiência para
implantar com todo esse ganhamos o
prêmio que foi o que abriu as portas e
aí perdi um amigo um colega da
universidade para colocar o nome porque
eu não tinha doutorado nexon em 2000 e
2008 que terminou o doutorado e aí 2005
a gente aprovou projetos finep que foi o
início realmente de todo o trabalho que
a gente tem feito dentro da área da
tecnologia assistiva e eu me inspiro
muito nessa frase da hbo que parece
pessoas a tecnologia torna as coisas
mais fáceis para as pessoas com
deficiência tecnologia torna as coisas
possíveis né e é o que a gente tem visto
realmente e o eta tem sido a prestação
de serviço a gente tem 80 crianças e
adolescentes com deficiências
articulamos alunos de graduação de
vários níveis de vários tipos de dar
este conhecimento é terapia ocupacional
fonoaudiologia e ciência da computação
engenharia eletrônica design
a gente está montando um deles com
design uma cadeira adaptada e
trabalhamos com a pesquisa com inovação
tecnológica com produção do conhecimento
isso o tempo todo está alimentando e aí
a nossa parceria com quase resulta a
nossa grande parceria com a sesu então
ensino pesquisa e extensão na área da
acessibilidade tecnologia assistiva e
inclusão né e então o impacto na
formação do estudante na geração do
conhecimento essa interdisciplinaridade
estiver na prática porque discute o
tempo todo os casos né e o impacto
social que isso tem gerado
né na com essas crianças a gente tem
acompanhado essas crianças na escola né
é quem trabalhar pesquisa bibliográfica
por aplicada pela equipe de
desenvolvimento e inovação trabalho
pesquisa experimental clínica ep de
biológicos têm levantado por exemplo a
gente levantou que uma das grandes
causas é de deficiência por paralisia
cerebral no pará poderiam ser evitadas
porque são por imperícia proíbe urbina
alta que aquele amarelinha da criança
que às vezes nem se atenta que realmente
é tão perigoso ou por problemas
neonatais virose uso que poderia ser
evitado se tranquilamente é e nós temos
trabalhado com o desenvolvimento de
produtos
aqui é um trabalho de capacitação de
professores que a gente tem feito várias
escolas inclusive orientar como ele
trabalha com as pranchas de comunicação
alternativa um projeto desenvolve está
sendo passado para tablet era o software
desenvolvem cpu agora está empatada
durante o s
já trabalhando já testando com as
crianças a roupa bill cinética que é uma
roupa que a gente tem é pesquisado com
roupas americanas que custa quatro mil
reais no domingo carro ali era 4 mil
reais agora com o dólar alto nem sei
quanto está ea gente está conseguindo
desenvolver na faixa de 400 e 500 reais
é que a gente já está testando com
resultados muito bons aqui o princípio
da roupa é de realmente dá um
alinhamento é o elástico da roupa para
facilitar aquele músico não somos só eu
acho que ele músico que não está tendo
função que ele possa estar colaborando
aquela musculatura a cadeira que é com
pessoal de design não é que a gente já
tem um protótipo agora e fez um
protótipo fibra de vidro e agora a gente
vai fazer em impressora 3d
o game a game terapia gente usa o xbox
eo nintendo wii como um trabalho de
reabilitação motora e cognitiva
os brinquedos e os acionadores a gente
mande da criança e pelo grupo pro preço
sistema de piscar vai ser preciso tema
de acionar pressionando com o pé com
culto velho
como ele consegue a gente faz passar
primeiro por um trabalho com um
brinquedo
esses acionadores eles são
confeccionados pelos nossos alunos que é
uma prancha de comunicação alternativa
que é o laboratório onde estão
confeccionando os selecionadores com a
parceria nasceu uma parceria com a ufpa
nós estamos desenvolvendo um software de
de comunicação alternativa que é o
próprio munique nec é em android e é ea
gente está testando também através de
bluetooth e também fazer o acionamento
pela pela ep um periférico é temos a
parceria com matheus com alessandra
concurso daqui de informática com a
testagem da de uma touca que a gente por
thomas já existe projeto se desejar
problema de desenvolver a própria
próprio dispositivo aqui que através da
sonda legenda do eletroencefalograma
essa essa garota consegue a ligar um
ventilador de ligar o ventilador acender
uma lâmpada desligar a televisão ea
gente quer avançar para que esse sistema
possa ser ela possa também acionar o
sistema de comunicação através de
computador de tablet o outro brincando
com a leitura que esse está coordenado
pela sesu culpa né a parceria nossa com
seis upas que é um software um
aplicativo de tablet e oeci onde a gente
vai estar trabalhando na escrita e
leitura de crianças com dificuldades de
aprendizagem
aliás ele pode ser utilizado por
qualquer criança mas com o ritmo como
ele é baseado num método de consciência
fonológica e de equivalência de extingui
reforça mais a questão da aprendizagem
daquela criança tem um ritmo mais lento
é outra parceria com a ufpa foi o nome
ficou
é esse é o vox lapse que também um
vocalizador o professor da ufpa
professor nelson neto é um localizador
pra pessoa não só o prouni e foi voltado
inicialmente para autistas e esse é a
pessoa de modo geral que têm alguma
dificuldade de linguagem é de
comunicação e recentemente tivemos nos
estados unidos
agora macho sabe fazer uma parceria
entre a unidade de bem lembrou edu era
pior que diz né e tb continua a ver o
cachorro aqui o cachorrão aqui também um
trabalho interessante se eu achei esse
cachorro ele foi treinado pra avisar as
pessoas que estão próximas ao paciente
que tem crise convulsiva ele avisa
quando a criança vai ter três como cima
muito interessante que ele começa a
agitar e aí avisa que ele a criança vai
ter uma precisão sem dó o tempo todo ele
está com efeito que um defeito num cão
de guarda né
e aqui é o trabalho da roupa a gente
está discutindo exatamente a inserção
trazer se esse método pra cá a belém
baseado também ter tentado trabalhar com
a parceria com a roupa que a gente já
desenvolve tive agora de 16 de 17 márcio
e aí eu vou deixar essa frase é esse
pensamento que eu achei muito
interessante do gaia sat que é quando eu
era criança e é exatamente o que eu
pensava eu costumava pensar o quão
incrível seria imaginar uma coisa e ela
simplesmente aparecer e pronto isso
ainda pode parecer até ficção científica
mas surpreendentemente a tecnologia
necessária para tornar isso uma
possibilidade já existe hoje tudo o que
está faltando é uma abordagem criativa
para construir a interface entre a mente
a máquina
obrigada
no brasil